mesdames messieurs bonsoir le black out
donc sur la chine plus d'image depuis ce
matin plus de téléphone avec les
correspondants de presse
en interdisant aux journalistes
étrangers de couvrir les évènements les
autorités chinoises ont montré leur
détermination à faire leur ménage
sinon santé - pas d'expulsion pour
l'instant du moins dans la discrétion
contrairement à ces dernières semaines
ultra médiatisé ce que l'on sait tout de
même c'est que la plus grosse armée du
monde 3 millions d'hommes et défier est
bloqué dans sa progression par plus d'un
million de chinois descendus dans les
rues de pékin des chinois qui appelle
les soldats à fraterniser avec leurs
mouvements avec francine raymond les
toutes dernières images qui nous sont
parvenues et les informations qui
filtrent d'encore la dernière image en
provenance de pékin filmer une
demi-heure avant l'entrée en vigueur de
la loi martiale ce matin à 10 heures le
premier matraquage de la police contre
les étudiants contestataires
la chaîne américaine cnn n'entrera en
direct le représentant du gouvernement
chinois a ordonné un arrêt immédiat des
retransmissions télévisées les élèves
des agences de presse sont interrompus
les journalistes chinois et étrangers ne
sont plus autorisés à donner des
informations à photographier ou filmer
dans les zones couvertes par la loi
martiale au lever du jour
on a vu ces images étonnantes des
dizaines de camions militaires stoppé
aux portes de pékin
cet étudiant imploré les soldats de ne
pas intervenir en souvenir de la longue
marche et de l'unité de l'armée et du
peuple un bruit circule le général
commandant de la 38e armée aurait été
limogé pour avoir refusé de marcher sur
pékin sa fille serait parmi les
grévistes de la faim pour mettre fin au
chaos l'armée populaire de libération a
ordre depuis hier soir d'agir sans
hésitation et par tous les moyens
ce matin des hélicoptères ont survolé la
place tienanmen ouvriers étudiants le
poing levé cris ou sommes vos frères
protéger le peuvent
par milliers les étudiants ont quitté
leur campus pour rejoindre leurs
camarades déterminé à s'opposer à
l'intervention de l'armée
leader étudiant exhorte les soldats à ne
pas bouger la population à s'opposer à
cette intervention par tous les moyens
légaux et pacifiques
les dernières informations signalé deux
graves incidents au sud et à l'est de la
capitale qui auraient fait des dizaines
de blessés à la mi journée une
cinquantaine de camions remplis de
soldats armés descendre et la route de
l'aéroport vers le centre de pékin
enfin selon un journaliste du quotidien
du peuple un étudiant gréviste de la
faim serait mort